Hey guys, good to see you. Sweet look at my shots. Yeah. Anybody wearing underwear today? What up, Shoddy? Where'd you guys get those microphones? What up, Shoddy? What's Shoddy mean?
Let's not. Why is that? What is it? What's the difference? It's cool. What does Shoddy mean? Shoddy is the... No, Shoddy.
I think Justin Bieber says Shoddy, doesn't he? Oh my gosh. What does it mean? All right, it's an onus Marlis says Shoddy, doesn't he? Oh my gosh, short. What does it mean? All right, it's an all new smart list. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart.
Smart. Smart. Smart. Hey, Sean, do you have an understudy? I do, he's great, Max Roel, he's amazing. Now, have you given Max a chance to get up there and do his thing? Yeah, one night, well, so one night, remember,
I changed smoked, right? I changed smoked on stage. And it made my vocal cords just massively inflamed. And I couldn't barely talk, so I was like, so I missed one show and he went on, he was fantastic. Oh my God. So now I took out all this stuff from the cigarette. So now it's the vape pen that lights up when you suck in, but it's just air.
So I took out all this stuff. You're still sucking. I'm still sucking. Hey, I just wanted to get that audio clip. And can you copy me and then the file that I've got going of of these guys things. Is that a sound meme? I'm really punchy today.
I took a volume last night just so I could sleep and it's like, are you still up to it? Not work? No, it works. But I'm just like, hey, how's everybody doing today? So we just have like a loose bottle of volume hanging around. What on earth stand? Is there like the Luber drugs that you need as popover? Do you not understand how prescriptions work?
Yeah. No, I take one every few weeks. What's the prescription look like on that? What do you mean? It's a volume. Yeah, but why do you have it? Because like if I have trouble sleeping like every several week, like I take one every couple months just to get back in the sleeping habit.
That's a sleep aid, huh? For me, it is. Do you know what a sleep aid is, Jamie? Yeah, it's called, uh, what's it called? Um, um, um, Gunja. Gunja gummies, ambience, annex. I had not heard of the volume.
Well, I'm calling JB last time I thought to Jason after seven PM is like, I read a man. That sounds I read. Let's talk tomorrow greetings in the name of his emperor. I said, I see I'm like, buddy, can you play golf tomorrow or not? No, Jay, valiums like it's the same family of Xanix and others. Oh, that's a real fun family by the way. It's like the Manson family that would accept me. No, we're saving a seat for you Sean. Oh, Sean, he had a good luck buddy.
Hey, listen, I'm feeling really punchy tonight too. It's so hot out here on the East Coast. It's unbelievable. Can you get it cooler before I get out there, Willie? I don't know man. It's so, it's so, it's so hot out here on the East Coast. It's unbelievable. Can you get it cooler before I get out there, Willie? I don't know, man. It's so, it's so, so hot. It's a thick. Very thick.
And I was just riding my bike into town. And I was like, graph way there. I was like, this is a bad idea. It's really hot today. But anyway, I'm really excited, though, to be back here, to be back inside, to be talking to our guests. I'm excited.
Our guest. I am such a fan of our guest and I'm also a personal fan of our guest. It's better not be a classy guest. This is a funny bro. Well, she is. She's both. She's very classy and she's very funny.
And I think that she's started much more serious, just based on her credits and the movies she did and the show she did, and then started to get into comedy. And it was just an absolute home run when it comes to comedy, but then can kind of flip back and still do the serious stuff,
which is really, if it wasn't so admirable, it'd be annoying, you know what I mean? It's all the while being like a really cool person. We've never really worked together, except for we did represent a country once together. And I'll explain that in a sec. So she's Australian, she's Australian.
She's in the prime of Australia. I think we know her from so many shows. Rose Bird. I love Rose Bird. Yeah, I got it. I love Rose Bird. Hi Rose. How's it going?
What are you doing? Is that a cute short haircut? Or we got it all up in the back? No, I'm just like a top nut. Well, you look how good you're looking to Bob. Yeah. You're looking at Bob. It does look like I've got a Bob.
What's it going? Hey, how are you? I haven't seen you for so long. Rose, where are you right now? Hi, friend. I'm in Brooklyn. Rose, where are you right now? Hi, friend. I'm in Brooklyn. Oh, Brooklyn, New York. Brooklyn, New York.
I'm in East Coast. Yeah, I just got back from Australia. Yeah. The country we both represent. For sure. And that's all I've got to come about. Can we stop there? She allowed me to come along for the journey.
She was really representing me. Well, it's helping me. I was just just talking about. Rose, there's no shortage of really talented, handsome, funny men that are actually Australian. So how far down the list do you go before you hit American and then to get to will our net on the American list? So it's a spot that you both did a commercial that you did for travel to Australia, right? It was a campaign for, yeah, to the most Australia. Thank you, Sean. Just in case your audience
was confused, who gives a shit if they know what we're talking about, or not, when you come to this, they don't want to know everything. How do we cast Will Arnett and that rose? Well, it was just my voice. It was playing in American. The character is a, you know, this far in American who comes in. And it's of, yeah, it's just a, he's a unicorn. Yeah, yeah, truly. I am. And my character is too. Yeah.
So you play an animated, you play an animated American unicorn. What a commercial. That's cool. Do you, do you do an Australian accent with it all? I mean, I don't really. I don't. I'm very good. No, I know.
I know. No, I know. You can probably. Yeah, he does a very good one. Do it. Just a little. Give us a little. Come on.
You're in front of the green screen. Shoot son. There's a. Oh, that's a knife. You love doing the knife one. Oh, yeah, that's not a knife. This is a knife. Yeah, that whole thing.
That's a bell. I mean, I get it. Oh, yeah, that's not a knife. This is a knife. Yeah, that whole thing. That's a bell. I mean, I get it. But then it becomes a whole thing about the dinghy when it ate my baby and all this sort of stuff. I don't want to get a track here, you know. Because then, wait, what movie was that for? Wasn't that Nicole Kidman?
No. No, Merrill Street. Merrill Street. Merrill Street said with a straight face. They're a really famous but very infamous case in Australia about a woman who was jailed for murdering her child, Lindy Chamberlain. And she tried to blame it on a dingo? Yeah, well, and they didn't believe her and she became this sort of national kind of
witch hunt for her and then she eventually was acquitted many years later. But it was a famous film with Meryl Streep. And that being line was in her big defense. And the big things, yeah, defense was a big thing. A cry in was and her big defense. And the big things. Yeah, defense was a cry in the dark. Yeah, it was. It was sort of enough
sterling equivalent of, of where's the beef. I think I think it was not a comedy. She said that seriously. She found the laughs. Merrill found the was a very serious case.
And we're not downplaying the the. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, such a cool, you're such a cool, fun person. And so exactly what I hoped you would be, which is like, super down to earth and cool. And I was like, and super talented. And you're like, wow, some people got it all. And then, you know, I work with these guys and some people have none. So, but the point is, it was just such a delight to get to know you. And I'm such a fan of everything you've done, which is a lot. And when I start to go through all your thought,
it's going to say, except for. No, I was going to, so what happens is when I was getting, knew that you were coming on today and I'm going through all the stuff, I'm like, oh yeah, Rose, isn't that? Oh yeah, Rose, isn't that? I mean, you have made countless films and television. I'm making the hay guys, making the hay. You've got to keep dancing. I'm really not just crunching.
So what was the first one? What was the first one? What was the big, what was the first professional gig that you can remember? The first job I got paid for, I did this movie called, Pretty Strange Little Movie, called Dallas Doll, not to be confused with Debbie, Dallas, Dallas. No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
it was a cool little script and I played Sandra Bernhard came out to do it to Australia in the early 90s and I auditioned and got this part. But I had started acting classes like youth at a youth program here in Sydney when I was like eight years old and then a casting agent came to one of my classes and cast me in this movie. So you had this, and you ended up going to, you did this acting class, did you end up going and studying acting as well, like in an academy? I didn't get into NIDA, which is like the sort of, you know,
most sort of well-known Australian, the National Institute of Dramatic Art, which is, you know, most sort of well-known Australian, the National Institute of Dramatic Art, which has, you know, very famous alumni. But I didn't get in, guys. Didn't get in. Oh, they're all out. So I just... By the way, they're kicking themselves now. And by the way, if you know an Australian, they kick themselves the other way.
Yeah, they kick the other way. It's not a lot of people know that. Not a lot of people know that, they kick the other way. But you know, I've worked with Jason too. I've worked out two out of three of you guys, which is you, I love you, I love you. I've worked with Jason too. I've worked out two out of three of you guys, which is pretty cool. This is where I leave you. Oh, this is where I leave you.
That's so nice. How long ago was that now? That was the comedy about sitting Shiva. Yes, it's where Jane Fonda. The Sean Levy, via Sean. Sean Levy, the great Sean Levy, Adam Driver, Cory Stoll, Tina Fey. Amazing cast, wasn't it? Yeah, that is amazing cast.
Yeah, we had a great break. So you guys, so, so, but so to go back, so you go back, you get this, you get this movie with Sandra Bernhardt. She flies all the way to Australia. You do this movie, then what happens? You that movie comes out and you're like, I'm sad. What?
What? Yeah, I'm done. Maybe what's a good old film? Literally just paired at the phone. Ready to roll. Then, no, I like I finished high school and I started auditioning for other TV jobs and stuff in Australia
and I got a few bits and pieces. And then when I was 18, I got cast in this film called Two Hands, opposite Heath Ledger, directed by this wonderful writer, director, Gregor Jordan, and that film was a really big hit in Australia, and that was like, you know, a sort of turning point, I suppose, for me, back home. So that was in like 99, 98 or something. I was like pretty young,
as I was Heath who was like teenage. So you have this big hit in Australia, like I'm out of here. Then I did the classic thing of going to LA to just try to audition for years, like I'm trying to get an agent. I remember I got my first agent. And I was so excited. I was like, I'm all set. I've got this agent. She's really great. She's got a great client list and she signed me off the movie and went back to Australia. Never heard from her again. Never heard. Never heard. Never heard. Never heard. Never heard. Never heard. Never heard. Where's the great Bobby Connovoly this morning? Bobby, he's unpacking. He's because we just got back. So he's like in the trenches with the kids unpacking, but he says hello to all
of you. Yes, Bobby Connovoi, who was on Will and Grace forever, playing Will's boyfriend. Yes, yes. And we played, he played my superhero boss, or super villain boss, and the thing with Melissa McCarthy, where I had crab arms. How did you guys meet? Bloody funny. We met through an actor called Tate Donovan, who was on Damages, which is a show, a TV show
I did with Glenn Close. Yes, you did. For a long time. Yes, and Marty Short was on that. And Glenn Kessler. Yes, yes. And Glenn Kessler and Daniel Zell. And then Zellman was one of the creators.
And Dan Hermeson used to be there. Look at all these connections. Look at all the guys. We're just crunching it out. Look at this. Yeah. Now, where are, is Bobby juggling that you have two young boys, right? Yes, and he has a third boy, Jake, who is 28.
Yes. Oh my God. He's got boys, boys, boys. Yeah. Wow. How do you guys do it? You guys both look so much. I mean, I'm sorry if you get this question a lot,
but it is just, I don't know how people do it, where you got two young kids and both parents are working all the time out of town. It must be tough, but are they both now in kindergarten or first grade? Yeah, they're both like sort of, but they've been, it's like, I've had to a job. It's a harder, right?
It's hard, yeah, because then they're in school school but it's a little bit case by case basis. I don't know about you guys with your families and children and stuff but a little bit case by case just do your best like time. Right. Sometimes the summer they can come but yeah. A little bit and they've gone to schools in LA. I don't know you know so it's like a little bit of that kind of but I guess older is it gets harder.
Pardon me as they get older, right? Well, it does get harder. It does get harder and it's a lot more of a negotiation and because what happens is they have friends. Jason knows this too. They have friends and they're like, you're like, hey, we're gonna do this thing. They're like, no, man, I wanna be with my buddies.
Right. And we don't care about your thing. Yeah, craft service is great, but. I know. That's such a joy card, they talk about that they just go I was I Going through a thing right now where my 14 year old is on a trip and I haven't talked to him for three and a half days now because He's his phone and
I am suffering Yeah, I bet he's having a great time and I am going crazy. Yeah, will you have no idea, you have no way to check in with him? Yeah? No, like a chap around. When he got there, when he got there, he was able to check in and he faced time,
I faced him and he was great. And then he checked in again later, he was like, hey, we gotta give up our phones now because the deal was on this trip that everybody gives up their phones and that these, these guys, these sort of counselor guys take them. And so we're like, yeah, this is really good. Meanwhile, we're, you know, my ex and I were like, this is great. This is great for him. And now a three days in, she and I were texting each other and he's like, how do we, What about the chaperone? Can you text chaperone? I mean, we can.
We know that he's, we know he's okay. We've gotten word and stuff. He's fine. And right before he gave up his phone later of the first day, I tried to, I tried to cram another FaceTime in. Less. And he was like, Dad, I can't pick up the phone.
What are you doing? No, I'm sorry. Yeah, yeah. Just making sure. Oh, I know. I know. I know that's it. A little you doing? Sorry. Yeah. Yeah. Just want to, I know. Just making sure. I know. I know. I know. That's a little Archie. Oh, people. Guys, Will's sweet. I know he doesn't seem sweet, but this guy got a real soft chewy center.
You're all sweet. My Rose, what's going on this summer? Um, do you have any time to take, uh, any family trips aside from Australia? Well, this was a pretty big one. It was like a month. Um, I was in the Outback. Will, I thought of you. You were. pretty big one. It was like a month. I was in the outback. Well, I thought of you. You were.
Yeah, we went to... We went to... We went to... Laru. We went to Uluru, which is the gorgeous, I mean, incredible, very sacred spiritual site out in the middle of... Middle of Australia, it's wild. If you ever get a chance to go, any of you, please, please,
to go. So, so funny, it's been Rosenai did this thing. We actually had this friend of hers who directed it, did all this, shut all this incredible footage all over Australia. And so, and then we kind of narrated our way as we, as our characters went through with this great footage.
So, I, it feels like Rosenai have been on a tour of Australia together. So that's why she's like, we were in, and I was like, we were about to arrive. I don't know what we went there. But I remember. Do you, I, I, I've dumbed up questions.
Do you miss it when, when you're not there? Like just a family, just a bit of that. Oh, I do, have you ever been? I've never been, I wanna go. Have you ever been a drag to you? I've never been a drag to you. I've never been a drag to you. I've never been, it's a very long flight. Have you, Jason? I've never been, I want to go. Oh Sean, you've never been this way. I've never been, it's a very long flight.
Have you, Jason? I have a bunch of times, yeah, I love it. I love it. I love it. I would love to go there. I will say though, and this might be controversial. When you fly that long, you would love for it to be... You would like the distance, you would like the difference of the locale
to be equal to the distance of the flight. You know what I mean? In other words, it's very similar to the U.S. in that people speak English and they look sort of anglo and they're all kind of, except they drive in this. It's a little bit like Canada, to me, which is great. I love Canada, but I can get there in an hour. You know, just like go north into Vancouver. I feel you were under the well. I'm getting a feeling that you are underwhelmed. No, but I guess in fairness, I was in Melbourne and in Sydney a lot, but I haven't been to the
outback. I haven't been up in Brisbane. I haven't been to surface paradise. Yeah, you're in the city and that makes sense. And I feel like this is the problem that we have in the world in general, which is all the cities have become so it's the same stores in every city, right? Like you can go, yeah, you can go to Paris or you can go to Tokyo or you can go to London or you can go to St. Louis and there's a, a Fendi store.
Yeah, and Sean, good news. There's a theory there and a commercial. Oh fantastic. I'm in. I don't mind the flight. There's a big. So wait Rose, you can get into a Vince. Go ahead, Sean.
I was able to sing a Vince in Australia. And that's a stretch. We'll be right back. As far as the sponsor by BetterHelp, so with just a short amount of time left to go on the Broadway with my show, you know, everybody always asks me, where do you live? I say the theater, because I go from my apartment to the theater and the apartment to the theater back and forth.
I don't really, really have too much of a life outside of what I'm doing right now. And so you start to feel stuck, you start to get stuck crazy in both my tiny apartment and the tiny backstage of the theater. And so, you know, it can drive you a little mad even though you're doing what you love doing. You kind of have to figure out how to cope with that. And you might need some help, right? And so sometimes we're faced with issues like this where we we're feeling stuck or feeling like cabin fever, you're feeling just the anxiety from being confined, right? So maybe it's not that and you're thinking about a
career change or feeling like your relationship needs some TLC, whatever it is, therapy can help you map out your future and trust yourself to find the way forward and it can even help you out of sticky situations like feeling like you're trapped, right? And so I talked to my therapist about the mental toll that it takes on to do five months of a show, and it's hard, it's joyful, but it's also mentally taxing.
So if you're thinking of starting therapy, give BetterHelp a try. It's entirely online designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists anytime for no additional charge. Let therapy be your map with BetterHelp.
Visit betterhelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month that's betterhelpagelp.com slash smartless. Smartless gets support from Viori clothing. Guys, you know I don't like to talk about my personal life. I try to keep my life as private as possible. But Scottie took me on a helicopter ride recently. And it was amazing.
It was incredible. We toured like the whole city and we got real close to the Statue of Liberty. I've never been that close to the Statue of Liberty. Wow, deja vu. Anyway, tired of sacrificing style for comfort or get this vice versa, look no further than Viori.
The performance clothing brand that combines both, Viori, offers the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet, making it the perfect investment in your happiness. From joggers to leggings to crew necks, Viori has everything you need to stay comfy and stylish, no matter what you're doing. So, back to the helicopter ride. It's running around, running around. Like, what do I wear for helicopter ride? Every single time I go on a helicopter ride, I go, running around. Like, what do I wear for a helicopter ride?
Every single time I go on a helicopter ride, I go in Viori. But next time, I'll know to bring an extra pair. For our listeners, they're offering 20% off your first purchase. Get yourself some of the most comfortable and versatile clothing on the planet at Viori.com slash smartless. That's VU-ORI.com slash smartless. Not only will you receive 20% off your first purchase,
but you'll also enjoy free shipping on any U.S. orders over 75 bucks and free returns. Go to VURI.com slash smartless and discover the versatility of VURI clothing. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, our thanks to Zippercruder for their support. If you're hiring, you know that it's incredibly hard
to attract top talent. And with the current labor market conditions, it's even harder than ever. That's why you want a partner who gets it. Zipp Recruder. Zippercruder knows how tough it is right now, but they've figured out solutions for the problems you are facing.
See for yourself, right now you can try them for free at zippercruder.com-smartless. Zippercruder is ready to tackle your recruiting challenges. To reach more of the right people, Zippercruder is ready to tackle your recruiting challenges. To reach more of the right people, Zippercruder posts your job to 100 plus job sites. Need to hire ASAP? Zippercruder smart technology finds great matches for your job sooner.
Want first dibs on talent? Zippercruder lets you invite the most qualified people to apply to your job. Plus, Zippercruder's pricing is straightforward. No surprise costs. Team up with a hiring partner who understands what you need, Zippercruder. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercruder's pricing is straightforward, no surprise costs. Team up with a hiring partner who understands what you need, Zippercruder. Four out of five employers who post on Zippercruder get a quality candidate within the first day.
Just go to this exclusive web address to try Zippercruder for free, zippercruder.com-slash-smartless. Again, that's zippercruder.com-slash-smartless. S-M-A-R-T-L-E-D-L-S. Zipperckutter, the smartest way to hire. All right, back to the show. But Rose, like, when you go there and come back, what is the culture shock? When you first move, like, what is the difference between... I mean... We'll still go it on the bits. What is the thing that you noticed the most...
What are the differences you noticed the most? About Australia and the US? Well, Australia is a little more laid back, I think. In general, the people are probably a little bit more laid back. And it's just a bigger... This place is just... You can't compete with the scale and the amount of people and things like Australia feels... it's just a smaller population it's like and they're called harder
and it's it's just it looks hot yeah it's not but only during our winter only during our winter it can be but you also like the people like they're just in that same sort of way that that the English have the same sort of thing and I think Canadians have this little bit as well maybe a common well thing there's just people have a better sense of taking the piss out of each other and themselves. They don't take themselves as seriously as Americans do. Yeah. That's on the whole. I know that that's a very sweeping generalization. So again, hold back your fucking letters. But I think I think that there is that thing about you don't take yourself to seriously. And that's fun.
There's a kind of, it's very fun. All the people I know in Australia, I guess a lot of them are sort of actors and comedians and etc. But there is that kind of fun vibe. Do you feel like they're more a united country than we are? Ooh, it's a good question. I'll look, it's definitely, how do you feel? I don't get real with her, dude.
I was curious about that. Because it's smaller and you're, everything you're saying will, I just thought like. I was gonna say though, it sounds like there's a lot more common sense sort of policies in way of living there than perhaps there we get into here just because of the opposite sides of things. Is it very separated here at least right now?
Yeah, I think the vision here at the moment is pretty extraordinary and pretty like it's not as it's not as extreme. Australians are used to government in their life a lot more than Americans are. So for instance, you'll have a speed limit everyone took the vaccine without any, you know, things like that. There's just more use to that involvement. You know, healthcare is free. Although it's just a thing. So it's like it's just a very different mentality
of government in your life. Very similar to Canada. Very similar. By the way, I saw you and you can't take it with you. Oh, you did. You were fantastic. Yeah, I love that show. It was my first show I ever did in high school.
Oh, really? That's what everybody was saying to me. They my first show I ever did in high school. Oh really? That's what everybody was saying to me. They're like I did this in high school. It was like yeah, but but to see to see a Professionally done like that it was fantastic James Earl Jones like Well, you I was gonna this what I was gonna. I was gonna. You've done a lot of theater in fact and you didn't you and Bobby did Medea band I Claim and and do you Do you have any great theaters to our sorry Sean? I'm sure you've claimed. And, and do you, do you have any great theaters to our,
sorry Sean, I'm stealing your theater? Yes, yes. What went, yeah, I want to know what went wrong and you can't take it with you. We want to save Faber and Color for Sean. Go ahead, Rose. And I'll see your Faber color. My favorite, that's what my six year old
asks me, look, my five years old. Welcome to Faber, that's a bit right. Yeah. God, any theater stories. I mean, I've had that person have a heart attack in row three. You know, and this is very, very paramedic. This is an Australian, I was doing a plan that to come in. And we were still doing the scene.
It was three sisters, the check-off play. And then somebody of a sudden the person just starts going, like that, just bumps over and the party. And did you have to go? We kept going. It was really weird. Yeah, I was going to say, did you have to go? We kept going. It was really weird. Yeah, I was gonna say, do you finish the show? We finished, not only do we finish the show,
but we didn't stop. We keep going. Stop the scene. So Australia, they're like, unless you've bitten by a snake, you just keep going, right? It's the snake that stops things in Australia. Not the hardest, the most powerful.
But did you keep going with the flag? We kept going. We kept going. And this poor old gentleman, I think, yeah, they came in and they took him out and everybody stood up and they put him on the stretcher and took him out. Sure. Did they check him for an overdose of a vagimite? Because I know that it's that that can be sometimes high sodium content. Do people still say fair income?
I mean, I don't think so. I mean, I'm sure they do. It used to be a big one, right? Yeah, it's a little bit dated, this slang, a little bit. What does it mean? Fair dinkam means like really or is that right? Isn't that a replacement for that? Remember Rose, when we did that thing, we did that Q&A and they asked me some Australian,
they asked me fair dinkam. And I said that that's Faradinkum is a term that's used to describe like somebody who's okay to hook up with. It's a Faradinkum. Yeah. Yeah. That wasn't that bad, but I like it.
I thought Faradinkum was like... Early 80s. Yeah, like more like, oh, do you... Yeah, it's a little 80s, probably. A little bit, it's a little bit dated, fancy couple. I got a rose, I got a good one for you. Yeah. I think I told these guys, what do you call chickens?
Who's, what do you call a chicken staring at lettuce? What? Chicken sees a salad. I've been using that the last 48 hours and getting a lot of folks. Rose, Jesus, I'm sure. Will, do you have any dad jokes? I don't have any dad jokes, not right now.
I'll have more by the end. Minor more just in the moment, like just. But here's how great Sean is. Sean just FaceTime me in the middle of the day or night, the other day I couldn't tell. And I was like, okay, I'll pick up the FaceTime. I'll pick up the FaceTime. And he said, he's picking up, hello. Hey, so just real quick, just for a quick, quick joke.
And then he tells me that joke and I laugh and he hangs out. That's right, that's the kind of socializing I enjoy. That's it. A little hit and run. And that's exactly right. I know you. I know you're so good. We came up the other day with, I was told Sean this, that thing. A little hit and run. And that's exactly right. I know you. I know you.
I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you.
I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know you. I know that. Nice little visit from the youth fairy. I like that. But here's the thing, Rose, what do you use on your skin because you look like you're 12 years old? Oh my.
Your skin is flawless. Wow. Oh my gosh. You look great. Yeah, congratulations. Congratulations. What do you do? What do you do?
I think it's all. Do you do all the scrubs and the peels and the thing and the thing? I think it's the lighting in here. I'm not trying to be. I think it's all lighting. He wants another name for your turn. You go to sleep early, you eat right, you kind of do all that stuff. All those boring things I guess, but it is very dark in here. It is dark.
It's got a soft light. It's a really soft light. What do you, what do you pick out on? What do you just love to pick out on through? Look at this. Say something, she's having a big soft, they're both having Coca-Cola's. But this is because I've got food poisoning on the plane. On the one back.
No. And nothing of Coca-Cola can't solve. Phil P, so I got the blood dog. Don't name the airline. I know, I know. I didn't, I was. Did you guys go through, did you stop? I don't know the airline. I know. I didn't. Did you guys go through?
Did you stop? We just stopped in LA. We changed planes and then on the way from New York to JFK. Just recently just yesterday. Yesterday I got in last night, but I was like throwing up the whole time. Last night? Oh, how do you live here doing this? Oh, no, I feel okay.
Yeah, I feel okay. Yeah, I feel okay. But it was so gross. Like the tiny bag of the plane. Oh, I feel okay, yeah, I feel okay, yeah, I feel okay, but it was so gross like the tiny bag of the plane. Oh, I don't know. I know. I know. So gross.
Food poisoning is the worst. Food poisoning takes over your whole brain. It's amazing. Yeah, it's like quite, it's like your whole whole. And you guys had the kids with you as well as you and Bobby and the kids. They were asleep though because it was the last leg of the flight. So it was okay. I've just never had it on a plane, but it was like, how much longer have you got left, showing off the show?
How long has it been? Um, August 27th is our last day. Oh, wow, okay. Yeah, August 27th is the closing night. Um. How do you guys know each other? Like, how do you all know? It's 23, 23 years ago.
I was his acting teacher. Wait, how, no, I, no. Yeah, I, and I still got acting teacher. Wait, how? No, I. Yeah, I still go to him. I'm still working on it. No, we used to play poker. I met, I met will actually before the poker thing, but we weren't, we didn't get close until we all started playing poker, like regularly every week. And then with Jason and with everybody and with blah, blah, blah.
And then yeah, we were just years and years ago. Years and years. And in that time, we've done two shows together. Shall we never even talk about? We were just And then yeah, we were just years and years and years. And in that time, we've done two shows together. Sean, we never even talked about we've done two shows together. What is it? We did up all night on NBC with Christina, Applegate and Maya.
And then we did the Miller's on CBS. Cool. We'd gone on the memory. Sean, we went on that trip and Sean called like a week later, calling back. He's like, I think I'm going to do the show with you next year. And I was like, Oh, yeah. Isn't that? Wow. Sean, did I see that you've got a compression sleeve on your right arm? I'm both. Yeah. Oh, from playing piano. Yeah. Yeah. Wow. No, I'm on the lifting weights. Yeah, exactly. Did you lift up a heavy exiled the other day? Did you, but it's not how the wrists, your wrists, some.
The wrists are a decent, they're decent. The short, I should hands at the end of every show. I used them before and then twice after every day. Did you, so are you a piano prodigy? Like from a... Sure. No, I started playing when I was five and then I thought I was going to be a conductor and composed music and be a concert pianist.
And then I got the acting bug early on. And then I became a music director out of college. And that's what you gave you the food poisoning, right? The acting bug? Yeah. No. Speaking of, I say fans, I took my first cold plunge, the other day rose, have you ever been doing your whole body?
I mean, so intimate. I'm so into it. Oh my God. I'm like, I never get into that stuff and I'm addicted to it. Rose, tell me about the first time. Tell me about the first time because what does that feel like? It's really? I want to, yeah, I mean, I don't know how you, I'm very... I didn't like it. Yeah. I didn't like it. So, do I end up liking it after two or three or four times? You kind of get addicted to it. I got it. I'm addicted like it. I didn't like it. So do I end up liking it after two or three or four times?
You kind of get addicted to it. I got it. I'm addicted to it. It's like you just because it's becomes like something you have to overcome and the the the the high afterward is just you and it's not even high You just feel really you just you relax you sleep really well I found really helps you me fall asleep and your skin looks amazing. Like it does something amazing. Thank you. That's what it was. So, but I built my first, I can't believe you guys,
you know that I built my first coat punch 10 years ago before anybody else did. I'm now building my third one out here. And I swear to God, and you just go away. So hang on a sec. When you say you built it, you're slapping together all the ceramic
on the tub there and running. No, no, no, no, no, running. I'm doing a lot of like, I should go there. Hey, keep working while you guys sitting around like. I'm gonna be a bit of a, wait, wait, I want to get out. I want to ask Rose, when you first put, because I kind of want to try it, because I do my arms every day. Yeah, yeah. But I want to, when you first put your toe in, I feel like it would be,
I might buy it would be so sensitive. I'd be like, I'm out. I can't do the whole, if you start with sauna, right? If you start, you're really hot. And then you get in it. Yeah. But I'm from Australia. So we swim in the ocean in the winter.
So we went to back home now, right? And I was still swimming every day in the ocean. And the water is freezing. And so cold. Yeah. Pretty cold, but I go straight in. And so it's a cold plant. No, what's your name? It's like a, it's just the original cold plant. Just having, but I go straight in. It's a cold plunge. It's like a
just the original cold plunge, it's having a cold swim in the ocean. I do the same thing. And I go back home in LA, I start every day with I had the sun as well, which I do later in the day with the cold. But in the morning, I do just straight into the cold plunge. Yeah. How long? How long do you? Like the other day, you know, if I can make it three minutes, then I'll be, then that's good. But you, but usually about two minutes. I mean, I'm too. In the morning. Yeah. Oh, that's it. I was told that you got to make it four. And I thought, I do. I was like, I was like, I do 30 minutes. Yeah. Three minutes.
But I keep my, I keep mine at 39 degrees. So it's very cold. That's the idea. Mine's not that cold. Mine's probably 45. It's not 30. Is there a way to do it where you build up the tolerance to the cold? Yeah, it's only for 30 seconds. That's even cooler. But it does everything. It reduces inflammation.
The benefits of it are so if you can do basically, if you can build it up, I forget what the actual number is, but it's something, it's not even that much. It's like if you can do 10 minutes, cumulative minutes per week, it does x-ball benefits. And inflammation is the root of all, now we sound like Huberman super layoff. I mean, hey, can you do like a frog boil type of strategy
with it where it starts sort of room temperature and then you progressively get it colder and colder and you end up staying in there for 20 minutes, you know, because you don't really notice it getting colder. Right. I guess, man. I don't know. I don't work for the fucking pool company, dude. Back to real.
You got it. How long have you, can you do it for Jason? It's just the first time I think I was two or three minutes. Okay, yeah. It felt all right, but how did you handle that, Jason? Like going, you're, you're, you go junk right away or did you go slowly? No, I went right away, but it was after the sun. So it was deep sweat. I was, I've never been hotter.
And then, yeah, that's, that makes it. So like, as, as I've been building it, so by the time, Jay, you get here, the new one will be built. So as I've been waiting for it for the last year I have this is true I've this big inflatable Temporary tub out here and and I go and I'll get like eight 10 bags of ice and I fill it in and I with with water And I make this big slushy ice thing and I and I do it like that. I sit in the ice. Oh, that's cool Yeah, Rose, I want to talk about your family
so listen when you and I do it like that. And I sit in the ice. That's cool. Yeah. Rose, I want to talk about your family. So listen, when you, what was it like growing up? Did you get pushed into this? Is it something you wanted to do? How did you get exposed to doing the thing you love to do? Well, I grew up in a neighborhood called Balmain. And there was a lot of kids in my neighborhood who used to go to the Australian theater for young people,
which is ATYP. And I, friends of a friend of mine was like, I think you'd really like it. And I was only little, I was eight. And that's how I started was just doing these classes after school and just loved it. Oh, really? Just loved it.
Anybody else in your family and do it? No, none of my siblings, not my parents, anything. The neighborhood we were in was, you know, somewhat Bohemian, I guess, sort of a lot of artists there at the time. It's a bit more gentrified now. But that was, yeah, that was how I started. It was going to ATYP, yeah, doing classes.
Has your favorite part of it changed at all? Or do you still love the same things? Um, I, yeah, I, I mean, I still get nervous. I still get nervous before every job. I still get panicked and think, how am I going to do this? How am I not going to screw this up? Like, I feel like the nerves are still there about it. Like I don't know if the actor's condition
is sort of, you can't really change it. Right, do you guys feel like that? Yeah, I mean at any time I'm calm, I end up doing a terrible job. A little bit of nerves keeps me focused. I think so too. I think so too. You know, but.
But you know, it's funny though, but you know, for somebody who you say that you get nervous or whatever, and I mentioned this before, you're always working, you have two shows in a movie out right now as of the time of this broadcast. You've got physical, your show physical, which is your thing about it said in the 80s, where you play this sort of like a housewife who's kind of discontented. I mean, there's more than that, but that's the log line I'm going to give you.
And then you've got Platonic with Seth Rogan, right, the show where you guys play best friends who haven't put on it. And then you have Insidious. And I'm like, yeah, this is like that, to have three major things out at the same time. I mean, it's unusual and it's a lot. Please, you have freedom to complain, go. Yeah. That's a lot.
Well, all the pressure. And do you feel the end? The press, exactly. So the press alone that you have to do for that stuff. And a little bit is like, be careful what you wish for. Do you ever feel like that? I mean, I'm honestly just you got to make a little bit, it's such a sort of, but I feel like when I've, you know,
get, it's judged by job, right? Like, when I got the scripts for physical, this was a few years ago, but it was just such an interesting premise and pilot and like a character I'd never really seen before, setting this really specific world of like, you know, how, you know, how the, how the wellness industry really began, you know, sort of reverse, reverse engineering that and that, and really looking at this illness of bulimia, which is something that's never really been examined before on screen in a way that wasn't like a punchline or wasn't sort of, you know,
and this was doing it in a way that I thought was really interesting and it's really anyways in story. She's the creator and she's been very much a touchstone for me in terms of like how we represent it. But I don't know about you guys, but I just always feel like the last job you do is maybe the last job you'll ever get. Oh, I don't know. I always feel so fortunate to get another job. Yeah, I'm like, it feels so hot, you know? It's this business that doesn't know on anyone's favorites, really, like it's so I very much have that.
We'll be right back. Smartlis has brought to you in part by State Farm. Hey, Smartlis listener, think of all the amazing things in life that are expressions of just you. For instance, the song you stream over and over again while you're in your 13th hour of gaming at 4 in the morning with all the light top trying not to wake up your roommates, or the recommendations that you share with your friends on the top six comedy podcasts that are the best to listen to on your way to the gym and back, or even your new haircut, which may or may not be an epic bowl cut from the 90s and hopefully is, everything that makes you, you, makes all the difference. State Farm believes insurance should work the same way.
Your plan, your coverage selections can be personalized by you. And the ability to choose the plan you want by picking the options that fit you like choosing to bundle your home or audio policies is what the state farm personal price plan is all about. Getting the coverage you want at an affordable price just for you. So are you ready to make things personal? Call or go to statefarm.com today to create your state farm personal price plan. Price is vary by state, options selected by customer availability and eligibility may vary. We're brought to you in part by GoodRx. Are you one of the millions of Americans affected by changes in your insurance status or loss of Medicaid? GoodRx is here to help with easy prescription
savings and straightforward guidance for navigating changes in coverage. With goodRx, you can instantly find discounts and save up to 80% on retail prescription prices. And goodRx is totally free and simple to use. All you need to do is search for your prescription on the goodRx website or app and show your discount at the pharmacy counter. It's that easy. GoodRx is accepted at all the major pharmacies in your neighborhood, including CVS, Kroger, Walgreens, Rite Aid, Vans, Walmart, Sam's Club,
and many, many more. And remember, goodRx doesn't just work for new prescriptions. It can help you save big on all of your refills, too. I have a friend who was discussing not necessarily complaining, but discussing about how much his medications cost. And I told him about goodRx and he used it and he raved about it.
Talked to me like a week later saying how much money he's saved. And I'm so happy for him, truly. So to start saving on prescription regardless of your coverage status, check GoodRx. Go to goodrx.com slash smartless. That's goodrx.com slash smartless. GoodRx is not insurance. and now back to the show. And then like I said, you like you started and you did a lot of dramatic stuff
and you did a lot of like huge movies you did. I mean, kind of, I sort of forgotten that you had done Troy all those years ago, which is so crazy. It might seem like a different lifetime ago, a little bit, right? Yeah, I was so glad. Talking about working on that, because that was in Malta, right? Yeah, I was.
Yeah, I was. I was. I was. I was. I was. I was. I was. you had done Troy all those years ago, which is so crazy. It might seem like a different lifetime ago, a little bit, right? Yeah, I was so glad. Talk about working on that, because that was in Malta, right? Yeah, in Malta. Jason's Maltese. Yeah.
I am. No. My grandma, yeah, on my mom's side. Are you being serious? Yeah. Yeah, I didn't know that. Look at his fingers. Show us your fingers, Jay.
Look at those big fingers for hauling nets. Yeah, it says you're going to have a little bit fatter. So when you pull in the fish nets, you don't cut through to the bone. Yeah. And you're funny. And I've got webbed feed. If I fall off the boat, I can swim. Have you ever been there? Yeah. Once when I was a little kid, I would like to go back. Will you're thinking about going, aren't you, Willie? Yeah. We're supposed to go a couple weeks ago and then we we bailed. But yeah, yeah, I am going to go back. Will you're thinking about going, aren't you, Willie? Yeah. We were supposed to go a couple weeks ago and then we we bailed. But yeah, yeah, I am going to go, I think in this they used to shoot a lot there. They shot, yeah, they shot
their. They're going to do more. They're going to do more. They are. Yeah, they're about to do more. So you go to Malta to do Troy with Brad Pitt. Brad Pitt. I mean, how old were you when you did that? I was like 12. I don't know. I was so young, I was like 23, and just it was pretty overwhelming. I was extremely shy, like I was very, very shy, and I play like a, I played Bruce Sayers who gets like captured and thrown to him as like a toy that he can, you know, do what he wants with. So it was pretty funny.
It's a lot of, you know, me tied up, like, excuse me, so I do what he wants with. So it was pretty funny. It's a lot of me tied up, but excuse me, so I do what you do. No, like, beast, you know, like that. It was very, very, very, very. Don't you kiss me on the mouth. You know, and yeah, I was really shy. So how did that come about? Like, what was the process?
I had done this movie called Wicker Park. This movie with Diane Krueger and Josh Hartnett and Matthew Lillard like in Montreal and from there I got an auditioned for Troy and a weirdly Diane Krueger also she played Hellenem Troy so we like spent two years together back like you know 20 years ago, yeah, it was such a huge insane budget and so many extras and so many, it was just, you know, a Peter O'Toole was in the movie. I remember, you know, he would be smoking, you know, he was incredible, you know, this legendary actor and he was very fond of us of me and we hit it off. We kind of got along and really well. And I remember him climbing the stairs of like one of the ancient ruins that we were filming at
and really breathing really hardly. You don't like going out the stairs and one of the PA's saying to him, I think you might have to give up the ciggy's Pete or something and he was like, oh, I should just give up the stairs. Uh-huh. And you're fired. That's the stairs. Uh-huh. Yeah.
And you're fired. That's so good. What an answer. I know it was good. He had all this. One of my dumb questions is, how hard is the American accent? I like asking people that. I know I love that.
Do you have a word that clicks you into it? Because you have such a great American accent. Oh, thanks, Paul. We had a lot of American TV in Australia, so I grew up watching Seinfeld and family ties and stuff like that. Yeah, so you learned the American accent from my sister? Is that what you're saying? Yeah, I mean, it sounded a little like justine.
I don't know. But I had this really hard dialogue once when I did damages. When I still say it to try, if I'm having fun, patty hired 24-hour security for Katie. Wow. That's what's the power. Patty hired 24-hour security for Katie. Wow. What is that?
What is that? What is that from? It's a damage. It's a damage. It's a damage. So ours are tough. Yeah, and the hydred. Patty hired.
That's a hard one. Higher. How do you say hired in Australian? Highed. Highed. Highed. Highed. Higher.
Higher. Higher. 24-. Security for kids. Yeah, we just, we just sound sort of efficient and great to sort of like that, that is true. We sound like a bunch of knobs. Yeah, let's be honest. That was really, that's my, that's my go to one I've done. But, um, but I love it. I kind of, if I don't have to do an accent, I feel a bit strange.
Like on Platonic, there was this whole mixed-hole I really wanted me to be Australian. And I was very much like, I'm not sure I don't have to do an accent, I feel a bit strange. Like on Platonic, there was this whole next doll I really wanted me to be Australian. And I was very much like, I'm not sure, I don't know. I just want to, you know, I'm quite, but then anyway, I agreed to do it. You did, Australian, but you were kind of, there were moments where you sounded cut, not totally yourself, kind of. A little bit right?
Yeah. In Platonic, I noticed that, because I watched it, I noticed that. Yeah. And you're so good in it Rose. You're so so With your countryman, sir. I know with Seth. I love we love and a friend of the show. We love Seth You you must love working with him. You've done a few things. You guys have done a bunch He's a great dude Rose a fan a fan of question, were you, was Bride's man, are you getting eagles from fans right now?
Yeah, was Bride's man as much fun making it as it is watching it, because I remember I went opening weekend, and I, yeah, back in the day. And I'm over. I was, I, it just come out, not too many people were talking about it, I was like the second day it was out or something. And I was kind of, I'm the one who told everybody about it.
No, and I remember emailing Wig and I'm just like, oh my god, I love that movie so much. And it was just, and then just became this huge thing. Exploded. But it's just, it's one of my favorite movies, it's one of billions of people's favorite movies all the time. But it looks like it was a blast
and you laughed every single day. And we did. It was one of those jobs where it definitely did have no idea that it would become such a beloved film at all. It was like a mid-sized film. It wasn't, you know, it was like, yeah. What was weird was acting with that many women, I must say.
That was bizarre. Like the big days when we had all those set pieces and it was just like eight women or, you know, all of the girls together, that was really unusual. Cause usually if you're in a film, there's not often you're the only woman or you're doing a scene opposite a guy
or it's very rare to have that. And that was, I remember thinking in those days, we're so fun. Cause we all really hit it off. It was like not, it was a very good vibe on set, and everybody was really fun. How often do you and Bobby get to work together? We've been, we've worked together a lot.
Jason, actually, yeah, we did Medea together at BAM right before the pandemic hit, which was pretty wild, because we saw that kind of coming in, like the audience is starting to slow down and New York starting to shut down and just word about what's happening is this thing and then we had our final show and then three days later the whole of Broadway shut down and I remember hearing, oh, there's a male show had it
and someone else and then and then New York just was like the apocalypse. Were you guys in New York or were you a pro? We're during the pandemic. Because me and the guys on the other podcast we have like real heavy duty opinions about it. The plan. The plan. The future on all the other podcasts. We got real opinions about what you government. It was such a. We were all in, we were all in LA. You were all in LA. Yeah. Yeah. We were all in LA and, um, yeah in LA and yeah and Bert and Bert think this thing trying to find it
Yeah, sorry it didn't work out that well for you, huh? It's been a real It's been a bummer It's it's been a bummer, but you know what kind of kind of and I love I love bridesmaids too I mean bridesmaid is so, so funny. And obviously, Wigg is, you know, Chris and we love Paul Fee. Jason, I've worked with Paul before. He's great. He's such a great dude.
And... Always in a suit. Always in a suit. Always in a suit. Always in a shirt. Always in a shirt. He had one of those VW bugs when they first came out. And you remember the little Vaws that they have in the front?
He had a little flower in his Vaws. Yeah. Yeah, right on the dashboard. He's just a classy guy. He's a classy guy and his wife is awesome. He's just a cool dude. But everybody in that movie and obviously Melissa and everybody just such a great cast. And Maya, so you've done that. You have to get about Ben Falcon.
And Ben Falcon, the great Ben Falcon. Who we love. I know. Now we're going to get texts from Ben Falcone. How did you not mention me? We did. Barely got it in there, Will. I know. Well, now Ben doesn't have to text us.
But then, so you do that, then you do, you start doing more and more comedy. And then, but you can also seamlessly go back. My question for you is, is there something that you haven't, because it feels like you can kind of do everything, is there something that you're like, what's the big thing that's out there that you haven't done yet that you're like, I want to do something like X? Is there something that kind of in the back your mind that's... Or stuff they don't call you for? Yeah. Why don't they call me for that stuff? Oh my gosh. I mean, for me, I feel like comedy and drama, like the stakes are even higher in comedy.
I think to make something funny is like, it is fun and all that stuff, but it's also, it's hard work in a different way. You know, like it's... But what's great about you is you never ask for any laughs. You know, you're always so great about... You know, some people, when they... you're always so great about you know, some people when they when they some dramatic actors have tried to play comedy, they they
just sort of like speak louder and make faces. You just keep it all very relatable and grounded and real and your brand of humor. I just for me just I love it. Oh hell yeah. Yeah. Well, let's say what about like playing what about somebody with a limp and a list and old age makeup and like that kind of character I was excited about. I would like to play We could arrange that Actually, I'll joke the side hamlet as a comedy. Something is really funny. It'd be called hamlet and cheese.
Yeah. Oh. I think we figured it out, guys. I'm going to pull CIA. I'm going to put it together. Bobby can play Ocelio. Ocelio. I'll feel yo.
I'll feel yo. I'm going to a little wig and a little dress. He'll be cute. I feel yo. I feel yo. But there's nothing that you're like, oh man, you don't like sit there and like talk to your friends at night. Why am I not getting this?
I imagine that you're always talking to your friends saying me. Is there somebody like a historical figure you'd want to ever play or somebody like in the public eye or some part you ever like really aching to do? Well, I did this show Mrs. America and it was set in the second way feminist movement and I played Gloria Steinem and that was extraordinary. I must say and I learned a lot of pressure. Obviously she's still reactive and you know she's extraordinary but that was really no fracking and that was definitely something I tried to get out of because I was like, I thought the first time
you played a real person? I threw that up. I have played Duchess to Polanyak in Sophia Coppola's Rand-Toinette, obviously Curson has, but I played a very, it was a very, very small pop, but she was a real person. Yeah, she was like, good time to go. Yeah, but nobody can really re-
nobody can really reference her and go, like, hey, she'd talk like that. Right, yeah, yeah. She put her in her hair on the right side. She's a little more obscure. Oh yeah, you're right. Yeah, you haven't heard of that. You haven't heard of it.
So were you pressured like having to do an impersonation or an accurate one, or did you kind of like do your version of her? Well, she's so different from me where she came from and grew up in Sanford. So it was a lot of technical work like that, but it was really fun. It was really, eventually it was really fun. And her look is just so specific, like her silhouette is so iconic. So it was just like trying to like get that silhouette. She's one of those few people that you know immediately kind of who she is. So just by her silhouette, so that was really nerve-wracking trying to
try and get that right and the voice and how she walks, so that was really nerve-wracking, trying to get that right and the voice and how she walks and all that was very, very specific, but really fun. But I mean, gosh, I'm inspired by so much stuff I see. Like I loved everything every year, once I thought that genre was great. I'd love to try it like that kind of wild genre, something I've never really, I've never been part of. That would be really, it's all about directors, right guys? Guys? Guys?
What do you do to, what's your thing you do to just sort of goof off? What's your down time thing? Yeah, you're watching like dumb TV to unwind. Are you a bike rider? Are you a cold lunch guy? Cold lunch guy? Yeah. Are you the cold lunch?
You do the cold lunch guy? I try to do that two or three times a week. And I'm, God, what else do I do? Are you a book reader? I do a book reader. I'm a book reader. And I'll watch a bad TV. Like Bobby thinks I'm pretty trashy.
Like he's like, baby, why are you doing it? Why are you watching that? Yeah, you ever pulled him down into your little cesspool of reality TV? No, he just wants to watch sport. I don't know. Yeah. What's he addicted to? I get caught watching golf all the time and I'm very embarrassed.
He's got a big live draft he does with like- Football fantasy. Rod and, oh sure. And all those guys, they do a big live draft every year. This year, they're not sure if they can do it, because there's some scheduling issues going on, so he's deeply unhappy. He's very unhappy. That's right.
But he loves the football. He loves the footy. And I've grown to like it. I don't quite understand it, but I'm, you know, I try to get into it. I think it's good to get into sports. It's a good like... It's a good TV product.
It's a design around advertising, right? Mm-hmm. Yeah. Yeah. It's a money maker. Yep. But I've been loving going to the theater. I saw a good night off, obviously.
And that's been great to get back. I should have felt like it was so quiet for a while, Sean. And then that feels like that's what Bobby and I loved. We just love to go to, we love to go to see shows. So that's been really fun to them. Yeah. And it is one of the great things about when you live in New York, you're being able to go and see. Yeah. Can I, can I ask, did you, have you had, Sean, have you had people on their phone, texting, phone calls? Yeah. Yeah.
One time. What do you do? Do you do anything? Do you still feel certain? Yeah. One night, it was the perfect timing. It was, oh, shoot, I can't remember the line. Some phone was going off and I had a line.
I told you guys I can't remember it is, but the line had to do with being quiet and I delivered it straight to that person. The audience. That whatever the line was. Did they laugh? Yeah, I got a little chuckle, little claps. Little claps. Because everybody, it's so annoying. But right in the middle of the last part where me and June,
the girl playing my wife Emily, we were crying together and the phone, tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt tt t Dump, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, dumb, and so we're just like, and everybody in the theater is like, what the fuck? I just go, so completely ruined the moment. But what are you gonna do? Yeah. Anyway. Anyway. We've been fun having Sean on the podcast.
Exactly. Rose, it is so fun hanging in, actually in a lot of ways was like all of a sudden like Rose is just kind of like the fourth. Yeah, thanks for letting Will and Sean and I catch up. Yeah. Like, you're just like, it's just like we're just hanging with Rose. That's the name of the episode. So easy to get along with Sean. So Sean and Rose, you guys don't know each other, right?
No, not really. But you guys would be great friends. I believe that. Do I think, Jay? Yeah. Yo, yeah, well, they're going to have a great time tonight. Rose is going to go back. Oh, yeah, go back.
Yeah. Jump on the subway. Helping my sister's hands. He's going to get there. She's got a bag in front of her. She's holding a bag on the subway. Yeah. Just in case.
I would love to see Bobby again, too. So we should grab a bite at this time. Oh, yeah, yeah. I'll tell him. Yeah. I'll tell him. Yeah I know Yeah, send Bobby our love He's one of the great guys and and thank you Rose for coming and do it I know your time and I was Topaz nervous. I was like oh my god
And drink a lot of electrolyte from your food toys Oh, we have a good advice. Thanks doc Okay and drink a lot of electrolyte from your food poisoning. Oh, we have a good advice. Thanks, Doc. Thank you. Okay. All right, we love you, Rose. Lots of love, Rose. Thank you. Thank you, guys. You too.
All right, bye, Rose. Bye, bye. Bye, bye, bye, bye. Of course. Isn't she sweet, y'all? She is. That's very nice. Very nice.
She's such a town. She's done like a hundred movies. I know. She's been nominated for like Golden Globes, Emmys for everything she does. Boy, she's like stunningly beautiful. And she's gorgeous and she's smart as hell and she's and above everything else, she's so cool and down her earth. Yeah, she's like, I wonder what the, I wonder what's the bad thing? What's the blind spot? Yeah. Like what's she doing?
She, she probably just got done with the podcast and threw all the equipment against the wall. Maybe she's nasty to babies. I said to some of these babies, it's just trigger something in her. I said to somebody recently, I said, I said, I said, I was talking to somebody I said, you know, you know, so and so he's got a real blind spot
and they go, you know, everybody's got a blind spot and I said, I don't see mine Nice. Jesus. That's very good. Yeah. Yeah Um, but you know what I love because here goes shot here. I know get it. Sean. I got it. Jesus Christ Uh huh. I love her. I love her. Let's hear her. I love her so much. Sometimes I wonder if she thought that I might go by take another by to my tuna sandwich interviewing her there it is. Sean go ahead. Was that it? No, that's fine. Take another
by my sandwich. Everybody can you are going to use now. Were you going to use bite? No, I was going to say it's nice she lives in Brooklyn because it's so near. Bye. Nearby. Oh, nearby you. Yes. Oh, nearby you. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. Well, you know, I feel like you did use nearby recently. I probably did. You know, what's the name of that one day in Australia? Oh, yeah, but here's the thing when you forgot to ask her if she spent any time growing up at bun die beach bun die.
Not even the word. That's not right. No, no, not bun die. Bye. Oh, bye. Oh, wait, wait, wait, there this guys, we're back. Who wants it? Who wants it? Sean, you know, bye! Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, SmartLess is 100% organic and artisnally handcrafted by Rob Armjurf, Bennett Barbaco and Michael Granterry. SmartLess
This episode was recorded on July 7th. Our next episode will be out in a week, wherever you listen to podcasts, or you can listen to it right now, early on Amazon Music, or early and add free by subscribing to Wondry Plus in Apple Podcasts or the Wondri app.
When we think of sports stories, we tend to think of tales of epic on the field glory. But the new podcast podcast Sports Explains the World brings you some of the wildest and most surprising sports stories you've never heard, like the teenager who wrote a fake Wikipedia page for a young athlete and then watched as a real team fell for his prank. Diving into his Wikipedia page we turn three career goals into eleven, added twenty new
assists for good measure. Figures that nobody would, should, have believed. And the mysterious secret of a US Olympic superstar killed at the peak of his career. Was it an accident? Did the police screw up the investigation? It was also nebulous. Each week, sports explains the world. Goes beyond leagues and stats to share stories that will redefine your understanding of sports. And their impact on the world. Goes beyond leagues and stats to share stories that will redefine your understanding of sports. And their impact on the world.
Listen to sports explains the world. On the Wondry app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to sports explains the world early and ad-free on Wondry Plus. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.